the byte administration has now
unleashed the most powerful law
enforcement apparatus in the world the
us department of justice against
american parents middle class parents
whose kids go to public school and who
voice any opposition whatsoever to the
racism now being pushed on their kids
why are they doing this because
something called the national school
boards association has told doj that
these parents are domestic terrorists
at a recent briefing at the white house
joe biden's chief flack apparently
agreed with that assessment watch
so does the administration agree that
parents upset about their kids
curriculums could be considered domestic
terrorists well let me unravel this a
little bit because the national school
board association is not a part of the
us government i'd point you to them what
the department of justice said in a
letter from the attorney general is that
quote threats against public servants
are not only illegal they run counter to
our nation's core values that is true
these were threats against public
servants threats against
members of the school board regardless
of the reasoning
threats and violence against public
servants is illegal that's what he was
conveying from the department of
justice threats and violence are illegal
they're rarely prosecuted if ever when
they're committed by loyal democratic
voters but that's not the point the
department of justice did not give a
single example of threats or violence
these are thought crimes that are being
prosecuted here erica sanzi knows that
well she's a parent and founder of
parents defending education and she
joins us tonight erica thanks so much
for coming on so you've basically
because
you want some say in what your own
children are taught by government
schools you have been likened to a
domestic terrorist where does this leave
you
so it leaves me frustrated but not
surprised over the summer the teachers
union signaled actually they didn't
signal they said explicitly that they
were going to
invest money in investigating parent
groups so we knew that something like
this might be coming and it's clear that
school boards and school officials are
simply not used to this level of
scrutiny um they are i was on a school
committee so i can say that this is
something new covid blew
you know
the curtain wide open and now parents
are expressing concerns over a variety
of things and it seems that almost
regardless of what it is that they are
expressing frustration about
they are
they are mocked they are dismissed or
they are told that it's going to cost
them many thousands of dollars to get
the information that they're asking for
so
we're obviously very concerned
particularly because it takes a lot
of courage for parents to go before
school boards and
express their thoughts and how they're
feeling about what's happening in their
children's school doesn't come naturally
to most people and so when we saw this
come down from the department of justice
we knew that it was an attempt to
intimidate parents into silence even
though they're not doing anything wrong
no
no in fact they're they're doing what
they're required to do as parents which
is look out for the best interests of
their own children and as citizens which
is to speak up with elected officials so
when there were concerns about police
brutality and the misuse of police
powers reformers pushed
for body cams and their argument was if
you've got nothing to hide why wouldn't
you allow it to be on tape and that's
happened across the country why don't we
have cameras in classrooms every single
classroom
so that's an interesting question and
the truth is i still come down on the
side against cameras though i certainly
understand the impulse for people um
wanting that to happen but i do take
your point about the hypocrisy the same
people that wanted to defund defund the
police now want to stick to the fbi on
parents
and the same people that were for can
the same people that were four cameras
are now saying that parents don't even
have a right to see the curricular
materials being used in their children's
schools
yeah so it really is like a deep
question whose children are they do they
belong to the teachers union or or do
you you are a brave person to persevere
in the face
of this and i appreciate i hope you'll
come back erica thank you